hello and welcome to math simplified
i'm dr umar malik and today in this
video we'll be talking about a very
important hormone in our body
the thyroid hormone and what happens
when you have low levels of thyroid
hormone in your body
the thyroid gland is a small organ
that's located in the front of our neck
wrapped around the windpipe also known
as trachea
it is shaped like a butterfly smaller in
the middle with two wide wings that
extend around the side of your throat
the thyroid has a very important job to
do releasing and controlling the levels
of your thyroid hormone
a main role of thyroid hormone is to
control many vital functions of your
body including your metabolism
and metabolism is a process where the
food you take into your body is
transformed into energy
this energy is used throughout your
entire body to keep
many of your body systems working
correctly the two hormones created by
the thyroid regulate how much energy is
being used in the body
when your thyroid works properly it will
maintain the right amount of hormones
to keep your metabolism working at the
correct rate
and thyroid disorders are very common in
fact about 12 percent of people will
experience
abnormal thyroid function at some point
during their lives
and an estimated 20 million people in
the united states are suffering from
some type of thyroid disorder
women are eight times more likely to
develop a thyroid disorder than men
also thyroid problems increase with the
age
and may affect adults differently than
children thyroid problems can occur when
the hormone levels
are too high or too low on this basis
the symptoms of thyroid disease can be
divided into two groups
those related to having too much thyroid
hormone also known as hyperthyroidism
and those related to having too little
thyroid hormone
also known as hypothyroidism in this
video we will be taking a short look at
how low thyroid hormone levels also
known as hypothyroidism
affects our body and what symptoms it
can produce
keep in mind that these are just
symptoms and they are not definitive
proof of the disease itself
so before jumping to any conclusions on
your own always consult a doctor
for professional opinion so let's begin
and look at the 10 symptoms you can
experience
if you have hypothyroidism number one
feeling tired one of the most common
symptoms of hypothyroidism is feeling
worn out
thyroid hormone controls energy balance
and can influence whether you feel
ready to go or ready to nap thyroid
hormone receive signals from the brain
and coordinate cells to change their
functions
depending upon what else is going on in
your body
those with high levels of thyroid
hormone feel nervous and jittery
in contrast people with low thyroid
hormone levels feel exhausted
and sluggish low thyroid individuals
feel unrested
even though they may be sleeping more in
a study
50 of people with clinically diagnosed
hypothyroidism
felt constantly tired while 42
of people with low thyroid hormone
levels said they slept more than they
used to
feeling sleepier than usual without a
good explanation
could be a sign of hypothyroidism
number two gaining excessive weight
unexpected weight gain is another very
common symptom of hypothyroidism
when thyroid levels are low metabolism
switches modes
instead of burning calories for growth
and activity the amount of energy you
use at rest
or your basal metabolic rate decreases
as a result your body tends to store
more calories from the diet as
fat because of this low thyroid hormone
levels can cause
weight gain even if the number of
calories eaten remain constant
in fact in one study people with newly
diagnosed hypothyroidism gained an
average of 15 to 30 pounds in one year
since their diagnosis if you've been
experiencing weight gain
first consider whether changes in your
lifestyle might explain it
if you seem to be gaining weight in
spite of a good diet and exercise plan
bring it up with your doctor it might be
a clue that something else is going on
number three feeling cold heat is a
byproduct of burning calories
even when you're sitting you're burning
a small amount of calories
however in case of hypothyroidism your
basal metabolic rate decreases
reducing the amount of heat you generate
that's why
low levels of thyroid hormone cause you
to feel colder than others around you
about 40 percent of low thyroid
individuals feel more sensitive to cold
than usual
if you have always wanted the room
warmer than people you live and work
with
this may just be the way you are built
but if you have noticed
yourself feeling colder than normal
lately it could be a sign of
hypothyroidism number four
weakness and aches in muscles and joints
low thyroid hormone levels flips the
metabolic switch of proteins towards
catabolism
which is when the body breaks down body
tissues like muscles for energy
during catabolism muscle strength
decreases potentially leading to
feelings of weakness
the process of breaking down muscle
tissue can also lead to aching
a study showed that 34 of low thyroid
individuals get muscle cramps in the
absence of recent activity
and one study in 35 individuals with
hypothyroidism
showed that replacing low levels of
thyroid hormone with a synthetic thyroid
hormone
called levothyroxine improved muscle
strength
and decreased aches and pains compared
to no treatment
weakness and aches are normal following
sternous activity
however new and especially increasing
weakness or aching in the muscles is a
good reason to make appointment with
your physician
number five hair loss like most cells
hair follicles are regulated by thyroid
hormone
because hair follicles have stem cells
that have a short lifespan
and rapid turnover they are more
sensitive to low thyroid levels than
other tissues
low thyroid hormone causes hair
follicles to stop regenerating
resulting in hair loss this will
typically improve when the thyroid issue
is treated
in one study about 25 to 30 percent
patients
seeing a specialist for hair loss are
found to have low thyroid hormone levels
consider hypothyroidism if you are
experiencing unexpected changes in the
rate
or pattern of your hair loss
particularly if your hair becomes patchy
or coarse number six itchy and dry skin
like hair follicles skin cells are also
characterized by rapid turnover
therefore they are also very sensitive
to losing growth signals from the
thyroid hormone when the normal cycle of
skin renewal is broken
skin may take longer to regrow this
means that the outer layer of skin has
been around longer
accumulating damage it also means that
dead skin
may take longer to shed leading to flaky
and dry skin
one study showed that 74 percent of low
thyroid individuals reported dry skin
additionally the study showed that 50 of
people with hypothyroidism reported
that their skin had gotten worse over
the past year
number seven feeling down or depressed
hyperthyroidism is linked to depression
the reasons for this are unclear
but it might be a mental symptom of an
overall decrease in energy and health
64 of women and 57 percent of men with
hypothyroidism
report feelings of depression feeling
depressed is a good reason to talk to a
physician or therapist
they may be able to help you cope
regardless of whether
the depression is caused by thyroid
problems or something else
number eight trouble concentrating or
remembering
many patients with hypothyroidism
complain of mental fogginess
and trouble concentrating the way this
mental fogginess presents itself varies
by person
in one study 22 percent of low thyroid
individuals described increased
difficulty doing everyday math
while 36 percent described thinking more
slowly than usual
and 39 percent reported having a poorer
memory
the cause for this are not yet fully
understood but difficulties in memory
improve with treatment of low thyroid
hormone difficulties in memory or
concentration
can happen to everyone but if they are
sudden or severe
and increasing there could be a
potential sign of hypothyroidism
number nine constipation low thyroid
levels can put the brakes on your colon
according to one study constipation
affects 17
of people with low thyroid hormone
compared to 10 percent of people with
normal thyroid levels
in this study 20 of people with
hypothyroidism said
their constipation was getting worse
compared to only six percent of normal
thyroid individuals
if you are experiencing constipation but
otherwise
feel fine try these natural laxatives
before worrying about your thyroid
if they don't work your constipation
worsens you go several days without
passing a stool
or you begin having stomach pain or
vomiting seek medical advice
number 10 heavy or irregular periods
both irregular and heavy menstrual
bleeding are linked to hypothyroidism
one study showed that about 40 percent
of women with low thyroid hormone
experienced
increased menstrual irregularity or
heavy bleeding in the last year
compared to only 26 percent of women
with normal thyroid levels
thyroid hormone interacts with other
hormones that control the menstrual
cycle
and abnormal levels of weight can
disrupt their signals
also thyroid hormone directly affects
the ovaries and uterus
there are several problems beside
hypothyroidism that can cause heavy or
irregular periods
if you have irregular or heavy periods
that disrupt your lifestyle
consider talking to a gynecologist
before worrying about your thyroid
if you have any of these do consult your
physician for further evaluation
once diagnosed the treatment of
hypothyroidism is by daily intake of
levothyroxine tablets
your physician will decide the optimum
dose by correlating your blood work
and improvement levels so friends here
were 10 signs and symptoms that may
indicate that you have hypothyroidism
to know more about other thyroid related
problems and how to manage them
stay tuned on our channel for our
upcoming videos if you like this video
don't forget to share it with your
friends and family you might just help
someone who is confused about your
symptoms
subscribe to our channel for more
content like this
we at med simplified are committed to
bringing you the latest content
if you like what we do and would like to
support us consider becoming a member of
our youtube channel or support us on
patreon
links are in the description below thank
you and see you in the next video